solar cells
[music]
hello
we have a goal so one
less thing to worry about i'm happy
we made a deal but i'm sad
that the uk is out of the
european union i don't think it's a
happy day
this is a good one gone
failed there's no luck
[  music]
the goal that i in this deal he
this contract can find back
i am satisfied with what have
brought together that took a long time there
will be the the
[music]
i am black anyway
the border after the other ask
the conversation with  boris johnson in berlin
he is convinced that he
will carry the are contract of approval of the ready bags and that's not so
much my thing that's his thing and
getting through
the eu has made its position clear
we are against these
military ones  assault there is
no real reason for this and he likes to say
that turkey allows its action to be such
isn't it a
sheep
that the jobs
are albig wants april wants
another argument for me nice
[music]
on the set fire to  be able to find that made
people miss that
you should see them
[music]
they say
wil
new yahoo make mobile benaglios
made at all in the passage that
sounds that still their soloists that sound
a bit complicated that are
realistic that was natural  fathi nor
the difficult like overnight noticed
the irish prime minister step also
made directly in britain
direct control
[music]
according to the
actually head of government can
promise that a parliament auto rad
instead
that happens on his side since
markovs try to bring this parallel
we are
then senseless in a press conference in
Berlin
these professionals
[music]